>> I COME FROM IS A CHRISTIAN
FAITH THAT TEACHES HUMILITY,
TEACHES LOVE.
THE REASON IT MADE ME FOR CLOSER
TO GOD IT'S THE EXPERIENCE OF
CARING ABOUT SOMEONE MORE THAN
YOU DO FOR YOURSELF.
AND HUMBLING YOURSELF, PUTTING
YOURSELF IN YOUR PLACE.
>> Laura: AND CHASTAIN GOOD
BUTTIGIEG HAS BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF MULTIPLE GLOWING
PROFILES.
ONE PARTICULAR PIECE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DESCRIBES
A CHILDHOOD MARKED BY INTENSE
PROPERTY AND INTOLERANT FAMILY
WHO TURNED HIS BACK ON HIM
BECAUSE OF HIS LIFESTYLE.
TONIGHT, CHEST AND HIS BROTHER
SAYS THESE STORIES HAVE BEEN
SPUN FOR POLITICAL ADVANTAGE BY
PETE BUTTIGIEG AND ARE HURTING
HIS FAMILY.
HIS "WASHINGTON POST" ARTICLE
CAME OUT, THE FAMILY HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED TO HATEFUL MESSAGES BY
SOCIAL MEDIA AND TAX, ONE
SUGGESTING THAT MY NEXT GUEST
KILL HIMSELF.
HERE, PASTOR RYAN BOSMAN,
BROTHER OF CHASTAIN BUTTIGIEG.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS, HAS YOUR
FAMILY HAD AN ISSUE WITH YOUR
BROTHER AND HIS HUSBAND, HIS
LIFESTYLE?
>> OUR ANSWER, LAURA, THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR COMING ON HERE BE A
PRIVILEGE AND HONOR TO BE ON
SUCH A GREAT SHOW.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION,
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
HE COULDN'T BE FURTHER FROM THE
TRUTH.
ACTUALLY HAS NEVER BEEN ANY -- I
LOVE MY BROTHER DEARLY.
I LOVE THE BEST FOR PETE, THE
STORY, THIS NARRATIVE OF THE
FAMILY SHINING -- COULDN'T BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: WHY WOULD HE MAKE
THIS UP?
>> THE WAY I SEE IT, IN SUCH A
COMPETITIVE, A VERY LARGE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD OF CANDIDATES,
YOU NEED TO HAVE A STORY.
I'M NOT GOING TO CUT DOWN ON A
MAYOR'S ROLE.
BUT AT THE END, IF YOU ONLY HAVE
THE MAYOR'S ROLE, AND YOU GO AT
THE HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE
COUNTRY, YOU NEED TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT STORY.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE BECAME VICTIMS
OF THAT, OR FAMILY OF HAVING
THIS RAGS-TO-RICHES STORIES
BEING BROUGHT UP ABOUT MY
BROTHERS CHILDHOOD TO GAIN
POLITICAL POINTS IN THE POLLS IS
THE WAY I SEE IT.
>> Laura: HOW SENSITIVE IS
THIS ISSUE OF FAMILY COMING OUT,
COMMENTING ON OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS.
I WANT TO PICK UP THE PHONE AND
TALK TO EITHER PETE OR YOUR
BROTHER-IN-LAW?
WHY COME ON THE SHOW?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU DON'T
JUST PICK UP THE PHONE?
>> TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, I
DIDN'T SIGN UP FOR THIS PAIR THE
ONLY REASON I'M HERE IS FOR THE
TRUTH TO PREVAIL.
IF IT WAS THAT EASY, THAT
WOULD'VE ALREADY BEEN DONE.
THESE COMMUNICATIONS, THAT
WOULD'VE ALREADY BEEN DONE IF IT
WAS AS EASY AS IT COULD BE.
>> Laura: WHEN WAS THE LAST
TIME YOU SPOKE?
>> THE LAST TIME WE SPOKE WAS AT
MY GRANDMOTHER'S FUNERAL.
>> Laura: ONE WAS THAT?
>> THAT WOULD BE COMING UP AT A
YEAR AGO.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU DESCRIBE
YOURSELF AS A CLOSE FAMILY?
YOU HAVEN'T SPOKEN IN A YEAR?
>> TO BE HONEST, OUR FAMILY
DYNAMIC HAS BEEN ROCKY FOR 9-10
YEARS.
WHEN I BECAME A BORN-AGAIN
BELIEVER IN JESUS CHRIST, THE
FAMILY DYNAMIC DRAMATICALLY
SHIFTED.
IF THERE WAS ANY SHUNNING, TO BE
HONEST, THAT WOULD BE MYSELF
BEING SHUNNED OVER MY BROTHER.
>> Laura: DOES HE FEEL AN
EXCEPTED DOES HE FEEL UPSET?
THAT YOU DON'T, YOU KNOW THAT
YOU DON'T VALIDATE HIS CHOICES.
HE IS WHO HE IS.
DOES HE FEEL BAD?
I DO NOT KNOW FAMILY DYNAMICS,
PSYCHOANALYSIS HERE, I'M NOT A
DOCTOR, I DON'T PLAY ONE ON TV.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT Y'ALL SHOULD
GET TOGETHER AND TALK.
TO ME, THAT SEEMS LIKE THE
BETTER THING.
BUT YOU SEEM TO BE SAYING THAT
PETE BUTTIGIEG, MAYOR BUTTIGIEG,
IS TELLING THE STORY.
I DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH, FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
>> LIKE I SAID, IN A CROWDED
FIELD, YOU NEED TO GET YOUR
STORY OUT THERE.
WHAT BETTER STORY TO HAVE THIS
RAGS TO RICHES TO MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE HE CAME FROM A MAYOR OF A
MIDWESTERN TOWN GOING FOR THE
PRESIDENCY.
HIS HUSBAND, ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," HAD BEEN
SHUNNED FROM THE FAMILY, KICKED
OUT BY THE FAMILY WHO SUPPOSEDLY
WAS HOMELESS, WHICH WE HAVE NO
MEMORY OF THAT EVER HAPPENED.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING HE
WAS NEVER HOMELESS?
>> NO RECOLLECTION OF HIM BEING
HOMELESS, NO SHUNNING --
ABSOLUTELY NONE.
>> Laura: IS ANYTHING HE SAID
TRUE?
ANYTHING HE SAID TRUE ABOUT YOUR
FAMILY DYNAMIC FROM YOUR
OPINION?
>> FOR MY OPINION?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
EVERYTHING IN THAT ARTICLE WAS
FUN TO MAKE A RAGS-TO-RICHES
STORY.
>> Laura: WE GOT TO GO, RYAN,
BUT WHO ARE YOU VOTING.
WOULD YOU VOTE FOR MAYOR PETE.
>> TRUMP IN 2020.
>> MAYBE WE'LL SAY YOUR COMMENTS
ARE POLITICAL.
I COULD SPEND THAT STORY.
EITHER SIDE WILL SAY IT'S
POLITICAL.